here is Mick Mulvaney Donald Trump's own
former Chief of Staff previous to Mark
Meadows saying Trump indeed may end up
doing prison time it's not the
underlying crime it's the interference
it's the cover-up that gets folks in
trouble and they have him with
significant evidence it looks like as to
obstruction so I think the chances of a
of a guilty verdict are fairly High and
the chances of of real jail time are
pretty high I don't even think I agree
with Mick Mulvaney and I've said all
along I don't believe Donald Trump will
do a day of prison time period however I
will say that over the last 72 hours
I have moved ever so slightly in the
direction of
maybe maybe there will be some jail time
for Trump